How's it going everyone and welcome back
to another video. In this video, we are
going to talk about a forex concept.
We're using EuroGBP for relative
strength. So, if you are trading EuroUSD
or GBPUSD, you are generally watching
the dollar. from the dollar. You are
then deciding if you want to trade euro
or pound and looking at the relative
strength between those two assets. And
this is actually a video I touched on a
while ago on my channel for using NQNES.
But let's talk about how to do it for
euro and GBP. So if the dollar is not
consolidating, that is when we're going
to look to trade euro or GBP. Now let's
say I'm not sure which is stronger or
weaker. Let's say for instance the
dollar is strong. I'm looking to short
one of these assets. Which one do I
determine I want to short? Well, I can
look at Euro versus GBP to determine
that. So, how am I going to do that? By
looking at Euro versus GBP, if that is
in a bullish trend, what does that tell
me? Well, if you remember back to our
fractions video, it means that the euro
is stronger and the GBP is weaker. So,
if I'm going to want to long something,
then I want to long EuroUSD since it is
stronger. And I'd want to short GBPUSD
since it is weaker. And that is all
going to depend on if the dollar is
bullish or bearish. Now, let's say
EuroGBP is in a bearish trend. Well,
that means euro is weaker and GBP is
stronger. So, if the dollar is bearish,
I want to then long the stronger asset.
If the dollar is bullish, I want to then
short the weaker asset, which would be
EuroUSD. So, what does this look like in
an example? In this case, we have the
hourly chart on dollar paired with the
daily chart on the dollar and the daily
chart on EuroGBP.
So, we can see that EuroGBP is in a
bullish trend. So, what does that mean?
Means that the euro is stronger and the
pound is weaker. If the dollar is
bearish, well, then we want to be
longing something. So if the dollar is
bearish, we want to choose the stronger
of the assets between euro and GBP,
which we determined using this chart was
euro. So we would actually want to look
to trade euro USD and go ahead and take
a long position on that as pairing a
strong currency with a weak currency
gives you a nice bullish trend. Let's
get into a few examples of this on the
chart in Trading View. So, here we are
in our first example and you can see we
are on the dollar. You can see we've
taken out this pretty significant low
from July and we have a nice reversal
forming off of it. We have Monday,
Tuesday, Wednesday forming this low. So,
I can anticipate candle 3 and four to
finish off the Wednesday low of week and
we can get a Thursday move up and a
Friday move up as well. Now with the
dollar being bullish, we want to find
out which asset is more bearish and then
we can go to EuroGBP to find that out.
Now if we have a bearish move on
EuroGBP, it means Euro is more bearish.
If we have a bullish move on EuroGBP,
then GBP is more bearish. So we want to
see what will happen here. Now with this
closure, I could frame it both ways,
right? We don't have a candle to closure
off the high. So, we're either going to
form a reversal off this previous day
low into a fair value gap and trade
higher. In which case, euro would be
stronger, pound would be weaker, and
we'd want to focus on the pound or we're
going to fall through this level and
then we can look for EuroUSD cuz Euro
would be weaker. So, what we're going to
do is go into the hourly chart. We're
starting off with a little bit more of a
advanced example. Generally, we can just
look at the daily closures, but it's not
always so perfect. So, here we have the
daily fair value gap. We have a
protected swing right here. So we want
to see if this level will hold here. So
let's see.
And there you can see what do we get? We
get a reversal off the previous day low
with an hourly change in the state of
delivery. So using my candle 2 video,
this is bullish. So if EuroGBP is
bullish, what does that mean for a
bullish dollar? We want to be focused on
GBP as it is weaker. So here we are in
GBP and you can see is there anything to
trade away from here? know we have
failure swings and so by taking a look
at that we would want to wait for those
failure swings to be taken out before we
could look to get on side with a trade
with taking a look. So now that we've
taken out those highs we can wait for
some bearish structure to frame it back
into these lows below.
You can see there we get a nice
aggressive closure and then expansion
lower. Now once we get this daily
closure we'll go back out to the daily
chart. So here we are. We have a
closure. We have a nice expansion on
pound here. And let's see euro. You see
how euro is not as weak and that's how
we could use euro GBP and we get this
expansion out of this fair value gap. So
going back to the daily chart on dollar,
right? We have closed outside candle 2.
If we're looking for a continuation
higher on the dollar, we're still
looking for the same thing. Which asset
is weaker between Euro and GBP? So
taking a look at EuroGBP on the daily
chart. Let's clean this up a little.
What do we have? We have a candle 2
closure out of a fair value gap and it's
also an ideal candle 2 closure because
it's creating a protected swing at the
same time. So this is quite bullish. So
if euro GBP is bullish that means euro
is stronger than the pound. So with a
bullish dollar we want to be focused on
GBP or GBPUSD.
So taking a look here we have a nice
bearish closure and we have closed
through the series of up close candles
there. Now, another tip you can use is
just looking at the individual candle
closures or the relative strength we
talked about in our relative strength
video. Comparing Euro and GBP, you can
just look at the candle closures as well
as the structure. Here we get a closure
through these series of close candles.
Here we look at Euro. It does not get
that closure through and it is closing
much stronger. So, you can see just
using that as an extra confluence, we
can be focused on GBP here and looking
for an entry lower. Now zooming in on
the hourly time frame, you can see we
have a consolidation here which I don't
want to trade away from. But by looking
at the correlated assets, you can look
at dollar here. We have ran out that low
on the consolidation which creates an
SMT. So we can then use that SMT on the
weaker asset and we can look to trade
away from this as long as we get a
continuation through this area. Let's
see. We do get a continuation. Maybe we
miss this move as it's traded too weak.
unless we can get some sort of
retracement and then get on side with a
move lower. The main thing I want to
talk about here is not lower time frame
price action and getting on side with
moves. It's about relative strength. So,
just to review this, we have a dollar
that is forming a reversal off of this
low. Once we are in those continuation
days where we're looking for dollar to
trade higher, what do we want to focus
on? Well, we want to focus on trading
foreign currencies lower. Well, now
between the euro and the pound, which
one do we want to choose? Well, that's
where we can use EuroGBP to determine
that. When EuroGBP is bullish, that
means the euro is stronger. So, if
you're pairing that with a bullish
dollar, you want to be shorting GBP or
GBPUSD. Now, if the euro is weaker, that
is when you would want to short that
against the dollar. But in this case,
EuroGBP is trending upwards. So, we want
to focus on GBPUSD.
Now this is where you can blend in the
phases of price the fractal model to get
on side with this move. But mostly we
want to see the fact that pound is
weaker and you can use euro GBP to
determine that. So if we take a look at
euro you can see euro does not get
nearly the move that GBP does and that's
why it's important to understand
relative strength and euro GBP allows
you to do that. So here we are in
another example and what do we notice?
We have multiple days of expansion.
Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday, Thursday
forms a counter. So, we can anticipate
Friday back into the range. So, a candle
2 closure. Candle 3 going back into the
range. Now, with a bullish dollar once
again, what are we looking to focus on?
Which of the foreign currencies between
Euro and pound is weaker? So, let's go
take a look at EuroGo GBP. What do we
notice? We have a nice engulfing candle
here. And yes, it did take out this
high, but it is engulfing. We can look
at the lower time frames to see if we
have a reversal off of it. We can go to
the hourly. That's not looking like a
reversal to me. So, I would trust that
this is going to move higher. If EuroGBP
is bullish, that means GBP is weaker and
the one we want to focus on. Now, what's
another way we can check this? Take a
look at the individual closures on Euro
versus GBP. Here we have that closure
which is bearish on Euro. What do we see
on GBP? A very bearish closure, right?
So that just confirms what we are seeing
that we'd want to see this move lower on
GBPUSD.
Not to take too much time, what do we
get? A very nice expansion lower. Now,
do we get that on Euro? No. Right? And
this is why it's so important to
understand relative strength. You could
be completely right on a trade idea, but
if you trade the wrong asset, you're
going to be caught off sides or not
catching an expansion. So see this is
the price action you get with euro on a
bullish expansion day on dollar but with
GBP on the same day what do we get a
very nice trend. So that is why EuroGBP
is so useful in just understanding
relative strength. So here we are with
our last example and once again we're
starting on the dollar. We have a sweep
with a candle to closure. So what are we
going to look for? If we are bullish on
the dollar, we want to see which asset
is the most bearish. We want to be
bearish on foreign currencies. So,
taking a look at Euro GBP, what does
this tell us? Well, this is a pretty
bearish candle, right? So, we can
anticipate this to continue lower as
long as it remains in respect to 0.5 of
this range. If we are bullish dollar and
euro GBP is bearish, what does that
mean? It means that euro is weaker than
pound. So if we are looking for the most
bearish foreign currency between Euro
and pound, what is it? It would be euro.
And so we can go ahead and take a look
at EuroUSD. And that would be the asset
we'd want to be looking to trade. We can
also just verify this by looking at
those individual daily candle closures.
You can see on EuroUSD, we get a nice
bearish closure, while GBPUSD, we don't
get that bearish closure. It's actually
bullish. We can go take a look at the
lower time frames here. We want to be
looking for a fractal model. We have a
change in the state of delivery. We'll
go ahead and turn my indicator on. And
then what do we have? We have price
opening up.
Sweeps out this consolidation high. So
this is where we'd want to see that wick
of the daily candle form if it's going
to form. And then do we get a
continuation lower? We do. Right. All
the way through these lows here. Now
let's go ahead and take a look at Euro
and GBP side by side. So here we are
with Euro and GBP side by side. Euro on
the left, GBP on the right. And what do
we notice? That relative strength does
come into play. Here we have the sweep
of the consolidation and a big drop
lower. And you can see at 8:00 a.m. we
run out this low. Well, we're not
running out this low till 9:00 a.m. And
GBP almost runs out its previous high,
while Euro has so much more separation
from that high. Now, I hope you found
this video helpful. If you get anything
from it, just learn how to understand
relative strength and weakness. And if
you haven't already seen my video on
relative strength and weakness, I'll
link that in the description below for
you to watch. But with that said, I hope
you have a great rest of your day and
I'll see you guys next time. Have a good
one.